[Music]
like to welcome everybody to tonight's
class on chest tactics as you know
tactics a little three to eight move
combinations to finish off a game after
you've established an overwhelming
position through a brilliant positional
and strategic play so the tactics is the
culmination of the game typically now
this first example is a very famous game
by an American champion named Frank
Marshall anyway black to play and win
and without further ado I'd like my
audience to suggest the winning move for
black I'm sure that ken has at least the
seen this game before it's maybe not the
younger people in the audience well I
believe Marshall was even before your
time yeah who said wreck h3 you're right
whoever said it Rick h3 have you seen
this before okay
now I'll make White's move he tries to
drive the Queen away and then he'll
moved the rook from c5 to c7 and
threaten Queen takes Knight pawn
checkmate that's White's idea now the
next move is the is the prettiest move
of this whole combination and Frank
Marshall in his book wrote the
spectators were so pleased with this
combination
they threw gold coins on the chess
boards at the end of it
what is the move for Blast
don't say yeah where would you like the
night to go f 3 square 14 the Queen e2
okay alright let's try it
notice that the little pop-up screen
says new variation when that happens
that's a sign that this is not the
official solution because I keyed in the
official solution but this is a it's a
good it's a good try but this isn't the
right move you need to be quiet Kim okay
who saw the answer we'd like to take
credit for it okay does anyone anyone
who didn't see the answer know what the
move is for black very pretty
I would never have seen it go ahead go
ahead
what's your answer Queen to g3 and
however white takes the Queen there's a
checkmate so if Rick pawn takes then you
get your night check and that's
checkmate because the wreck guards the H
file okay now if this pawn takes again
hold on [ __ ] this takes new variation
then the knight comes down check the
forcing the King over and rook takes
rook is our checkmate
and last but not least Queen here again
the knight move over Knight takes Queen
check the rook bonds pin
where it takes right but I was puzzling
I was puzzling because can we avoid meat
by moving the king over ken what's the
move here maybe there isn't a mate here
you just do the knight check and you
move the rock on h3 over to a3 and wipe
out the a2 pod and you're going to be
piece up and you're gonna win some pawns
on top of it all right okay okay
obviously black is going to win this one
cuz black has an open work file the rook
is aiming toward h1 protected by the
bishop black has to act fast though
white is the queen that can do a check
on eight this is a very tricky
combination if you like to play and
checkmate white with a series of
brilliant moves almost all checks
well that nice protected by a pawn would
you like me to take it off the board
let me say don't be shy in sacrificing
work work in this position as a hint
yeah let's look at that
yeah Bishop dates do great you saw that
but we escaped up here not what happens
yeah
now what said it that's it very good you
solved it I'm impressed I thought it was
trickier than that okay let's see who's
winning this game whites kings in a bad
way so is black I would think that makes
a lot of sense too well let's see what
what the computer what what it is oh it
is Queen to c5 now what's the follow up
move who said Queen to c5 what's your
follow up move that was good very good
that's coming but I would suggest you
save that for the mate
how can you draw the king to a mate with
that 96 mate yeah that's the right
sequence then a stock wait a minute
what's that
efore square although we have to
continue now what's the move
f3 takes the spawn now what's the move
King here yeah how do we check them now
h3 back here now what that's it we
finally tracked him so that so takes is
let's run through it again it's kind of
pretty this is by the way not a game as
you might have guessed it's a
composition by like some guy who put a
nice composition together I forget his
name and the only square open is the
white square on e4 then the other the
pawn comes up he has to take the pawn
that Knight comes up he has to go here
the knight goes here forcing them here
and we go here and that's our checkmate
okay let's look at this one
I think you're right because black has
those pawns shoved down White's king's
throat and white has no pieces that can
even attack black uh all whites pieces
are behind his his pawns which is a
horrible position so black has to win
and he guesses we won't spend a lot of
time on it I think this is the number of
moves we would have to see but anyone
like to guess on the starting move
anyway I'm gonna say when in doubt check
the King which would be pawn takes pawn
check the other possibility would be
with the other pawn g3 takes h2 but I
like h3 takes with that check and then
we can shove our Knight up to h4 with
check so maybe something like that well
wait a minute it's White's move pawn
takes Bishop here oh look a discovered
attack by the rook
he can go back oh he takes listen that's
it we'll go back after a bit he could
takes it clean up now he's coming into
our territory so this is good this is
pretty easy
castles checkmate
I thought castles was a defensive move
to get your King out of the center yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go back here
you go white to move we thought it was
black white plays H takes g3 black takes
with check here King takes black throws
the bishop up yes take the bishop or he
loses the rook okay now the knight
discovers now we said what happens if he
goes back to g2 let's digress did you
get what you needed Jason King back no
93 check for King the king and queen is
better and you just take the Queen and
win that way okay did everybody see what
they wanted to see on this one okay okay
so what would would be I forgot to tell
you the theme of tonight is where we get
the King out from behind his pawns and
we force them across the board and trap
him so that's what we're doing we've got
two more of these all right let's look
at this one it looks like maybe white is
attacking white is has the only piece on
the fifth row which is a knight yeah I
remember this one so who would like to
make a guess at it and then I'll just
show it to you
Wight to play and win the game and it's
a very surprising move that white comes
up with the only way you can attack your
opponent is to move your pieces forward
so they're not a piece that moves
backward no defensive moves by white and
you can't be afraid to sacrifice bishops
or Knights either
well how about sacrificing the other
night that's lagging behind on h3 well
let's look at Knight to g5 and obviously
the main line he has to take the knight
but we get to take the pawn attacking
the knight we get the knight back if he
moves the knight we open up the F file
on that f2 pawn Knight takes pawn or
Rick takes pawn probably it leads to
winning attack well if he doesn't we
have two Knights they're attacking the
f7 pawn which he can't defend so what
the knight that's being attacked by the
pawn the knight on d5 would take the f7
pawn and that would be a one game right
there blacks position is destroyed he
has a isolated pawn on e6 and White's
Bishop sir and Knights or aiming toward
his king he wouldn't last long so pawn
takes Knight pawn takes pawn let's see
what black does oh he can't move the
knight we're already talked about that
Knight takes pawn would threaten the
rook and the Queen could come up could
also come up to h5 at some point what we
could do rook takes pawn on f7 bring our
Queen Queen up and then we would
threaten work takes G pawn check King
takes Queen to h6 check
that might not win oh we can win the paw
yeah Queen to h5 then we would threaten
Queen takes pawn check and we would also
be able to play at some point pawn
tonight six and we can bring our rook up
and slide it over to the h3 or h4 and
finish the King off in the corner all
right so he brings the reserved night
the night an f8 up to protect his his
knight on f6 no he throws away this is
other night this is getting difficult
King takes okay oh you have a nice pin
so Queen Queen h5 o even g6 now we got
to get our queen up there somehow right
oh we have that e6 pawn looks juicy
let's take that which way do you want to
put your King on f8 or h8 how's it over
oh ok so there's no choice now we all we
got to do is move our work up and we can
aim it to h4 right we can go work to f4
and go to h4 I think let's see nope
oh the bishop comes up and is going to
replace the Queen on e6 with Czech then
the Queen can go to h8 and finish blacks
King off from the back row Knight covers
the e6 square
and now what that's got to be it tonight
he has to go over again but we did clear
up some wood that was defending the king
didn't we
now we I can't do work to F for the
Queen covers that square now what
where it takes Knight Bishop takes and
finish him off Ken
now what cut the King off with a rook
move and then we lower the boom with the
Queen move so he the only way he can
block that 4:1 move is moving the bishop
up oh now the bishop in fourth at g7
pawn is free for the taking
we're not going to let him get away are
we who would have thought we'd end up
checkmate he's down b2 yeah sure sure
well he didn't have to see the whole
thing because he could see that once he
got the King up there it was all over he
probably didn't see that he what he
might have he's good enough to have seen
it but he didn't have to as all I'm
saying obviously white must have the
King hunt somehow because the queen is
on h5 and the white Bishop is on d3 and
that the knight can take the bishop with
check dis unleashing the bishop on the
h2 this is pretty simple who would like
to give the winning move for white Ken
that's a surprise I thought Knight takes
Bishop Bishop takes pawn check would win
okay now we get double check if if he
goes in the corner there's a Knight to
g6 is checkmate
okay ken what what do we do now and I
think we need I need your help on this
one
which night yeah let's check with that
night it's got to be here
the king has to go here yep it's got to
be the pawn that forces him here and
here and here and here here here work
the h2 King here oh yeah why not
wait wait wait new it like just I don't
see anything wrong with castles but it
like the King up there yeah I guess it
would work too okay so these were the
exciting ones tonight now we're gonna do
some routine ones where we win a piece
or something okay so the unprotected
piece white to play and win let's point
out the unprotected pieces in blacks
position who would care to elaborate on
that for us
Bishop on c2 what else both rooks the
now you know when you have two
unprotected pieces and the Queen looks
to attack both of them so that White
Queen is no way is going to attack that
unprotected work on a a right it's
impossible but you got to get the
sequence of the moves right Ken and then
he moves the rug oh by the way who do
you think White was it was the only
other American world champion before
besides Bobby Fischer Paul Morphy back
in 1858 he was mopping up one of his
opponents in this game you guys got all
the moves all you got to do is put them
in the right order one is the pawn
shoved one is the Queen move you could
move the rook but what would you or
would you move the right well then the
bishop goes to f5 and the bishops
protected and you don't have to
unprotected pieces any longer Bishop to
five the knight can take it but the pawn
can take back now that doesn't mean
black might be lost because of his bad
pawn position but that's not the what
we're getting at here what there's a
straight-out win of a piece here or a
winning attack if somehow black can SAP
not lose the piece okay so we said Queen
this e3 the bishop moves right and Ken's
idea was Queen to c3 and then we do the
pawn shove right how about inverting the
order do the pawn shop first
then you could threaten both pieces at
one time and the Queen the punk is
threatens to break black spawnposition
with pawn takes pawn check King would
have to take and the King is open for
further attacks so that's the idea of
course Paul Morphy the world champion
saw Bishop back the only movie had to go
to a protected square now pawn takes he
can't do Queen takes he has to do King
takes now the Queen here hitting the
five pawn queen here rook here rook here
rook here now rook takes rook pawn
Teixeira Queen takes pawn doesn't cut it
because there's rook takes pawn check at
the end attacking the king and queen so
he moves his King up to protect the pawn
white brings the other work over
threatening rook takes rook forcing
black to do where it takes rook and now
do we do pawn takes rook or a rook takes
rook I think we do rook takes rook
so you see though black King is in a
weak spot isn't it it's not covered by
pawns but White's King has some
difficulty too if the black word could
come to d1 that would be a checkmate so
white needs to move the Queen and he
could go to g3 check move that rook pawn
up to h3 that would give the King an out
then white can continue his attack
that's what happens so rook comes down
threatening mate check King back there
now H up and we have our White's King is
now safe but blacks King is still
exposed let's just run through the
solution black played up here to guard
the second row white played here to
double the working Queen on that file
and
maybe the work would go up to e8 at some
point or the work will go to e6 and
attack the queen from east six he put
the pawn up here I guess he's just
evening out his palm position he's
taking away the c5 square from white
pieces now the King the white King moves
up so there's no checks on the back rank
before he does something decisive he
moves that pawn up the queen drops back
here attacking the a6 pawn and
threatening to go the Queen to h5 once
again threatening the pawn on f5 Queen
came over
now the rook goes to e6 Queen back and
now Queen here the Queen and work or on
the f5 pawn no that just the Queen's on
the pond so he brings the rook up to
protect the pawn he just pawn here now
black plays pawn up here white takes the
pawn black retreats here he wants to
trade rooks looks like he's surviving
Queen takes pawn check Queen here Queen
takes rook here and white white one the
ending there wasn't a brilliant
checkmate but white won the ending yeah
but actually the computer says I got to
tell you what the computer says let's go
in through it one more time so it's here
bishop here takes takes takes King takes
here here here here here here work here
takes takes here check
pawn here black could have equalled the
position here according to the computer
is not in my book
so my author said he said you know they
like to say and white one with a strong
King side attack that's what he said but
the computer says black and equalized in
this position so let's see oh yeah
here's the note rook takes e5 and the
author's note in the book says and white
won by his King side superiority but
notice I have an equal sign next to it
that's the computer evaluation so work
here's fine here oh by the way King to
f7 leads to equality after h3 see f7 is
better it's toward the middle of the
board it's better than the corner and
instead of going to d7 defending black
can make use of his pawn on c6 to get
the to try to trade rooks and the rook
indirectly protects his pawn on f5 this
is the right defensive idea white has
nothing better than here pinning the
rook threatening to win a pawn and then
black let's the b7 pawn go but he he
protects the work with the Queen and if
the White Queen takes to b7 pawn then
white wins rook takes rook pawn takes
rook and he has Queen takes pawn
protecting his c7 pawn and then he'll
get a perpetual check against the open
King so this it should have been a draw
anyway we're gonna have to wrap it up
because there's another lesson in a few
minutes so we'll stop here thanks for
coming
[Music]
you